[Musica]
[Applauso]
sono convinta che quando si riceve in
dono un talento sia necessario quasi
obbligatorio respiro agli altri e farlo
vivere nelle sue piene potenzialità sono
anche sicura che ciascuno di noi abbia
un talento anche chi non lo vuole
riconoscere e che tutti sappiate di cosa
sto parlando
a cinque anni suonavo il pianoforte a 24
ancora suonavo il pianoforte avevo fatto
poco altro nella vita
tanto studio e sacrifici miei e della
mia famiglia i viaggi per studiare e per
esibirmi ea quel punto nel pieno
sbocciare della mia carriera che mi sono
resa conto improvvisamente che per me la
musica non era la soluzione non era
abbastanza e non mi rendeva felice il
teatro era un luogo tra posterò buio
chiuso e così che da un giorno all'altro
dovuto abbandonare offre tutto alle
spalle del mio pianoforte avrei voluto
strappare le corde riporvi la biancheria
o inscatolato tutti i miei cd cancellato
i numeri di telefono di colleghi smesso
di andare ai concerti di andare a teatro
e di frequentare chiunque parlasse di
musica ha fatto svariati lavori
insegnanti elementari la vivaista la
cameriera collaboravo in una scuola di
kung fu che è stato il mio primo sport
il mio primo grande amore l'unico filo
sottile che mi ha sempre legato al mio
passato di musicista è stato
l'insegnamento e attraverso i miei
allievi che ho scardinato quelle
certezze che avevano accompagnato tutti
i miei anni di studio e attraverso le
loro difficoltà che ho rimesso in
discussione ciò che per me era dovuto
scontato
in quegli anni vivevo montagne avevo
straordinarie opportunità da scalare
nelle alpi a mettere mano sono liti di
granito in california salire montagne
più alte di 6.000 metri
maya e poi c'erano le gare di
scialpinismo con le pelli di foca e di
corsa in salita aveva girovagato per il
sudamerica la tenda il sac a pelo da
sola attraversandole anni e poi quando
tornavo in liguria alle pagaiate nel
mare blu infinito con la mia canoe le
nuotate e le falese di roccia di finale
è quella volta che al tramonto scalavo
nel deserto in giordania e dal lontano
villaggio la preghiera del muezzin
giungermi librando materializzandosi
attraverso la roccia così che io la
potessi toccare trattenere una preghiera
scolpita nella pietra
ero felice esisteva in quanto persona in
non piu soltanto in quanto pianista di
sentire di note che da tutta la vita ero
abituata ripercorrere e accoppiare
finalmente interpretandoli floreali
sotto i miei piedi era un mondo a
portata di mano e io ho pensato più
volte in quel momento se esistano gli
angeli devono sentirsi come me adesso
perché il premio non era più l'applauso
del pubblico il consenso della critica
ma era lasciata di notte con la luna
ero felice ma qualche cosa mancava
io però non sapevo ancora cosa
una mattina nell'hotel di montagna in
cui lavoravo solo preparando un
cappuccino mentre andavo a portarlo al
tavolo osservavo la schiuma che era
liquida che colava dai bordi della
tazzina e proprio in quell'attimo mentre
osservavo quella triste schiuma compreso
si e guardando la schiuma che ho capito
se si ha un talento non si può ignorarlo
non si può gettare è vietato
io so fare la pianista io devo tornare a
fare la pianista ho posato la tazzina ho
annotato su un tovagliolo di carta io
sono una pianista e tornerò a fare la
pianista sono andata dal cliente col
sorriso stampato abbiamo chiacchierato
gli ho detto sarah
ma io ero una pianista quando
sparecchiato trovato una piccola mancia
sotto il piattino chissà magari è un
incoraggiamento
mi sono mangiata 2 brioche di gran gusto
proprio come quando si è giunti a una
conclusione
smontata dal servizio ho preso riuscì le
pelli di foca e sono andata nel bosco
come di consueto sotto una nevicata
copiosa con la consapevolezza di aver
compreso una cosa importantissima
io sarei tornata a fare ciò che già
facevo ma questa volta sarebbe stato
bellissimo coloratissimo il teatro non
avrebbe più avuto pareti sarebbe stato
un teatro a tutto tondo il mondo si
sarebbe trasformato in un palcoscenico
io mi sono risvegliata ogni mattina
facendo la pianista e desiderando farlo
erano dodici anni che non suonava il
pianoforte limiti tyrone irrigidite dall
attività usuranti come spaccare la legna
accudire gli animali
fare l'orto tirare i pugni nel sacco da
boxe scalare nella roccia e la memoria
non parliamo di quella l'idea di suonare
per più di un'ora tutta memoria davanti
alla gente mi sembrava ancora una cosa
impossibile
ebbene sono andata a comprarmi una
pianola
ricordo ancora l'imbarazzo e la pietà
del venditore di pianoforti che mi
conosceva come ex pianista in quel
momento mi guardava a provare poco più
di frammartino e avrebbe voluto dirmi ma
come hai fatto ridurti così
sentivo la sua sofferenza e la sua pena
ma non importava io non ero triste
facevo piano bar nei ristoranti negli
hotel e ai matrimoni camuffare mi dai
musica classica suonati al rallentatore
per melodie mielose hero antiche mixa
bobba che con vasco rossi e qualche
volta venivo beccata da un commensale
che si fermava con la forchetta a
mezz'aria che i tool che inizia intruso
stai suonando sciupano che ammiccava
regia io ero orgoglioso era una gioia
per me perché sapete questo è stato il
mio primo pubblico le prime persone che
mi hanno riascoltato sola
bisognava riguadagnarsi la credibilità
nell'ambiente musicale trovare il modo
di farsi ascoltare
io in cui anni ho chiesto aiuto i miei
genitori mi hanno sopportato con ogni
mezzo anche i miei amici mi lo davano mi
invogliavano posso davvero dire viva
l'amicizia ma proprio le persone a cui
io tenevo di più a cui mi sono rivolta a
trepidante per avere un consiglio mi
hanno rifiutato mi hanno sbattuto la
porta in faccia dicendomi sostanza il
tuo tempo è scaduto
c'è un tempo per ogni cosa potevi
pensarci prima ora arrangiati non ce la
farai mai faceva male però è anche
grazie a loro che ho trovato la forza di
dimostrare che invece è possibile si può
fare perché io avevo un progetto in
mente sarei tornata a suonare e non solo
bene ma anche nei luoghi più belli della
terra e così che ho registrato il mio
primo disco come vi frugali in una
chiesetta sulle alture di genova
inaspettatamente ricevuto il consenso
della critica e del pubblico e questo mi
ha promesso di tornare a fare i primi
concerti veri a questo disco ne è
seguito un altro e un altro ancora è
l'ultimo ha dimostrato che l'inedita non
erano più e ruggini the funzionavano e
come è brillantemente infatti contiene i
brani che liszt e funambolo del
pianoforte scrisse dopo avere ascoltato
ineguagliabile paganini sul violino
silver toso genovese aveva così
impressionata che vuole trasporre sulla
tastiera
ciò che lui faceva suo violino il
risultato con le i brani così difficili
che all'epoca gli editori non vogliono
pubblicarle è la critica insomma userò
per summa musicista insigne critico
musicale disse non più di 4 5 persone al
mondo potranno suonare questi brani a
dire il vero neanche lo stesso autore lì
sono mai in pubblico la dedicataria
clara wieck famosa pianista dell'epoca
non gli veniva fatto gli steli riscrisse
alcuni anni dopo in formula semplificata
ecco io non solo lì o sono
ma sono la prima donna al mondo ad
averli registrati
che cos'e ero una pianista un alpinista
una al pianista dovevo trovare il modo
di far convivere le due cose i miei due
amori la musica la montagna è una mia
amica un giorno è un'idea perché non
andiamo a suonare su monte rosa sai un
luogo importantissimo non è mai stato
confine di guerra al contrario ha dato
molti la salvezza al tramonto si tinge
tutto di rosa e la via l'insediamento 1
anno più alto d'europa alla capanna
regina margherita voluta appunto da una
donna alla reggina oa che idea mi metto
a cercare in lungo in largo che potesse
seguirmi in un'impresa così folle perché
io sarei andata a piedi anche una forte
non ai piedi lui pesa 400 kg e bisognava
trascinarlo fino alla sua ci voleva per
lui il passaggio di un elicottero e
quindi un bel po di denaro nomi nascondo
che a tratti l'impresa è sembrata
impossibile a volte quasi inutile oltre
che folle ma io ci credevo e ho trovato
chi a sua volta ha creduto in me ha
finanziato interamente il progetto è
così l'otto luglio 2017
ho raggiunto a piedi con i ramponi
imbrago e la corda il palcoscenico più
bello della mia vita ho suonato per 30
minuti ai 4.500 metri del colle gli
effetti sul monte rosa o meno 15 gradi
tenevo alle mani guanti perché la cosa
freddo che la pelle sottile delle dita
si appiccicava ai tasti congelati
rischiando di staccarsi ho suonato per
me le mie montagne e per tutti quelli
che avevano smesso di credere nei sogni
in un ormai più suonato senza quella
luce nella mente in quel momento mi è
stato chiaro ciò che già avevo intuito i
sentieri di note
i sentieri di montagna non sono affatto
di simili e un infatti di note e colori
pause silenzi gli altri fatti di pietra
ghiaccio baratri spazi forse ambedue
opera di lina ebbene dalla bellezza e
l'energia di quel luogo è scaturita la
volontà ferrell a gioia incontenibile di
trasmettere con la perfezione di
proporzioni perché vedete se normalmente
noi pianisti siamo abituati avere un
palco intero per noi sotto le luci dei
riflettori col pianoforte lunghissimo la
sua coda noi con l'abito elegante e bene
la io ero una cassetta piccolissima
insignificante sul ghiacciaio
questa è la realtà era come essere
sospesi nello spazio della verità in un
mondo ideale nel quale ogni volta che
chiudo gli occhi su un palcoscenico il
suono voglio trasportare i miei
ascoltatori come walter bonatti lo
scrittore alpinista diceva la conquista
di una vetta non è una mera conquista di
un punto geografico su una mappa me è
una conquista del sé se avete un sogno
anche il folle non fatevi convincere da
nessuno seguitelo credeteci lottate
lasciate che sia il bello a condurvi per
mano perché non esistono un premio più
grande della strada che si fa per
perseguire un sogno durante la quale ci
misuriamo c superiamo ci conosciamo e
cresciamo a volte cerchiamo ovunque cosa
passare invece felice per poi renderci
conto di avere crociati averlo già
incontrato magari di saperlo già
passerebbe permettergli di rifiorire e
guardarlo con occhi nuovi
questo è esattamente ciò che è accaduto
a me e non è finita qui ho in mente
altri progetti folli e magnetici e la
mia musica va avanti nella luce vi
racconterò
[Musica]
all
[Applauso]
[Musica]